disney animated animal characters  reimagined as beautiful people  now there's a glow up you don't see  every day see your favorite fish  cats mice dogs and lionesses from  disney's classics in a whole new human  light  we are living for these digital drawings  by the oh so talented artist isabel  [Music]  staub  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we can't wait to hear which animal to  human glow-up you love the most  which transformation are you taking  styling tips from tell us in the  comments section and hit that like  button to show your love for disney's  cutest creatures  thanks for watching